hello, how are you, greetings to him and
jaramillo with his brief information for
today, tuesday, september 7 this morning
we are going to start with new vigués
since the authorities are
investigating three homicides, the most
recent occurred around nine
o'clock at night about sangenís  'becks'
yesterday officers said a man
was shot and died about
an hour before this a man was
shot and did not survive very close to
this latest incident north of
shanghai close to being examined the
police department reported that
five people died over the course
of the long weekend
the third homicide occurred around
half past seven at night this
happened near niece gert on las
vegas boulevard and select another
man was shot and did not survive
so far the police are located  on
the trail of the suspects in the
three crimes
and if you are looking for a job there are
resources available to help  r the
process to you and tells you that you can
visit on play and be dotcom so you
can create a resume and be prepared
for an interview in the near future
there are other resources like the club and
versioning located on austin near
tour and paint this center is open  monday through
friday 8pm to 5pm and now
moving on to the weather forecast
we will have temperatures reaching
108 degrees by today there is an
extreme heat watch in southern nevada
through wednesday night we will continue to be
above 3 digits  For the rest of
the week, remember to stay hydrated
and avoid being exposed to the sun for
several hours. Have a nice day. Greetings, Alijar,
friend, and this was your brief
hopeful newsletter in Spanish
[Music]